Good evening, sir.
Good evening, sir. Good evening.
I was on a call, uh, an can you
Anand able to hear me?
Yes, sir. Yes, sir. I do You have my WhatsApp number?
Yeah, I do have it, sir. Yeah.
Can you send me a high message? Will I want to talk to you?
Sure, sure, sir. Done. I'll do it.
Good evening, sir. Good evening. Good evening.
Uh, Rakeesh, I,
I should not be telling Raj.
Yes, I saw
your name displayed.
Thank you. Uh, thank you.
Good evening, sir. Good evening. Good evening. Good evening.
So the, you are not changing your sitting
position from that Seattle?
Uh, now what? This California bridge? Yes.
Uh, Raje ish was always behind that.
Something like, I like beaches, but
after I put,
good evening, sir.
Good evening. Good evening. Good evening. Yeah.
Good evening please. Good evening, sir. Good evening.
Good evening.
Um, one
We can start with, uh, this, uh, GRU,
Uh, Yes, sir.
And, uh, once, suppose we covered the GRU.
I also have the same, uh, few slides
after your slides. I have put it there.
Mm-hmm. And then we can, uh, suppose you finish,
actually, uh, we can go with the DRN networks.
No problem. No problem. Yes. So let open. Yes.
Have to gimme a minute.
Recording in.
Okay. So,
okay.
So, uh, last Saturday, what did you cover?
L-S-T-M-I explained once again,
and then I show, I did the demo for the REST team. Yes.
Wonderful, wonderful, wonderful.
Because that is one of the mostly used, uh,
rrn, uh, networks.
I, that's a good job. So, okay.
I think, uh, first we discussed about RNL SST
and, uh, uh, now we will move on to the next variant,
which is called, uh, gated, uh, recurrent, uh, unit.
Um, which is, Uh, uh,
we can say structurally, uh, slightly
simplified version of, uh, LSTM.
So that's the way, um, I will say, um,
which is, um, of course these two statements are the same.
It's a variant of foreign meant
for processing the sequential data.
The difference between A GRU, uh, such as, uh,
and uh, LSTM network, um, is based on how it handles
that information flow, essentially, in terms of, uh, gates
that uses information flow is controlled.
That is what it is. Uh, definitely GRUI cannot compare
with RNN, I have to compare with LST.
Okay. Um, so, um, here,
for example, um, if I go for,
um, uh, the
get recurrent unit, you can look at the, uh,
pictorial representation here.
Since we have spent enough time on LSTM,
we had three independent gates in case of LSTM.
So in place of that, there are two, uh,
gates here, two gates here.
So that is the, the basic, uh, difference.
And, uh, so that is structurally,
if you see there are three gates,
of course the nomenclature will
become slightly different now.
So, uh, here I have simplified
in two, uh, no two gates see.
One is for example, um, uh,
and also the, the signal flow, uh,
is slightly different here.
The, the first thing is re reducing the complexity in terms
of, um, uh, not reducing requirements
of three gates to two gates.
And the second thing is the information flow.
Of course, that context unit,
everything a slightly different way they do it here.
Okay? So that is the, uh, difference.
Suppose you, you see this now here
there is something called a CT
and HT that, as I explained in the last session,
the HT is the short term, uh, information
CT is the long-term information.
Now here they use only ht.
That line itself will play the dual role
of short term and long term.
So that is the way it has been.
So accordingly, you know,
you draw the information from the HD line itself
for computing various, uh, um, uh,
know inputs required different points of time, both LLTS,
of course the logic, maybe even, um, when they were doing,
of course historically, if you see first the developer GRU,
and then they segregated into LST historically,
but LSTM became so prevalent.
That's when our RNN we study LSPM.
But, uh, no, if you want to slightly simplify the structure,
you can look into GGR.
So maybe the logic when the, all this, uh,
recurrent unit was, um,
uh, if you see here was a quick, you know, for a while,
if I look at the L SST m
carrying the short term information,
and at a very sequence position
or a time stent, I will update this long-term
information, okay?
And use that long term information
wherever I required or something.
Now, since at a very cell cell level, you are
updating the long term information.
Why can't I use the same single line
to keep the track of both?
That is the way, uh, the logic the matter employed, okay?
Single state line.
This STN carries both short term, uh, information.
Mm, and long term contextual, how it'll do we'll see.
So suppose, you know, uh, first thing, if we assume that,
you know, the single line will carry both the short term
information, long term information.
So that is one part.
Now, for example, if I, if I go back to, uh, LSTM,
I need HT minus one, XT minus one to first to compute
the current state information.
So for that purpose, I carry from the HD line
that, um, information and the XT line,
and this combined thing happens here.
And that is, um, um,
let me, uh, whether I can have a, okay,
so that this is nothing but the entry point.
What is there in the LS team, okay?
That is, and that passes through a sigma here also.
It goes through a sigma gate,
and that is what that sig gate it goes through, okay?
So, uh, uh, if you see
from HT minus one xt, you combine here, that is the same as,
uh, in the LSTM, that point,
and that is pausing through a, uh, sigma gait.
Uh, sigmoidal gait, same thing.
It happens year. And then the multiplication
of the long term happens since it carries both short term
and long term, that multiplication happens here.
And that multiplied information, um,
I take it through the tan hyperbolic function
will get the, uh, the, the
possible context vector here.
That's what this HD TILDA will come, whether it'll be added
or not is multiplied by this gate sigma gate update gate
and output gate there.
The, the, uh, opposite functions they do, that's where no,
I, in one case here, I multiplied by one minus
and then multiply with the sort of information,
the other case directly that state information goes there,
output state information.
So that is how the modifications have been done.
We'll see in the following slides.
But before going there, I just want to summarize that, uh,
what we have done is we have reduced the complexity
of the LSTM cell information instead of two parallel lines
for holding the state information separately
for short term and long term.
We are using a single line. That is the first thing.
Second thing is instead of using three gates,
I'm using only two gates.
That is the difference.
Otherwise, the functionality wise, everything remains safe.
So accordingly, if you see
the gated recurrent unit will have a simplest structure
with the two gates, uh, which is update gate
and reset gate they call, okay?
Uh, the reset gate is nothing
but that, uh, whatever the earlier case for gate,
gate was there, that is the reset gate here.
And update gate is nothing but a combination of both.
Uh, input gate and output gate like that. Okay?
So that's what it'll do.
You accordingly, you know, you will have fewer parameters,
three weight matrices or against four weight matrices
accordingly, faster to strain, uh, compared to the LSD.
Um, of course, see this are all space complexity is related
to the less compared to LS team, okay?
Um, but performance wise almost, uh,
know, uh, both are the same.
Definitely know when you have a long-term context
information to capture.
Uh, then I need to compare with LS TM and JRU.
And what they have observed is, uh, similar
performed similarly to LSTM and many tasks,
but in some cases, and this is gated as shown
to outperform LS TM and vice versa.
Um, of course, uh, there there's no, you know,
great logic there.
Um, um, especially, um, uh,
there is no clear edge.
For example, when there is a long-term context information
captured in any sequence modeling task,
then it is known that we have to use LS team or GRU.
There is no comparison with reference to RNA.
So the specific choice among LS team
and GRU is only in terms of complexity.
Otherwise, performance wise, there is no preference
of one over the other in a big way.
Okay? Um, so, uh,
here for example, uh, whatever the architect,
GRU architecture, LSTM cell, we are replaced
with the GRU cell.
So that is the difference compared to L-L-S-T-M case.
Um, so it combines three main compound,
only the update gate, reset gate
and the candidate in state, okay?
The current cell at the particular
of operation will take a decision on how much
to be considered from the past state
and how much should be forgotten.
And accordingly, it has two gates,
reset gate and update gate.
So if you see the recent gate on the update gate,
the state I'm taking state and the input state,
and that combined information is coming here, that you,
you have to go back to that equation, which, um,
I showed
at layer from the RN case, uh, weight metrics
for each path and their combination
and the update gate, each of the, uh,
a single layer neural networks model, neural network, that's
what one weights are different in each case.
One trained for, uh, acting as a update gate, another to act
as a reset gate, okay?
And that is that output is taken and
accordingly, you know, uh, you, uh, take it as an output
or combine it as a new state
and slightly going deeper what the reset gate will do.
Okay? So you have, um,
the reset gate as the name itself indicate, it'll
identify the unnecessary information which need not be taken
further as a long-term confer, uh, information.
So accordingly, it'll consider know what dimensions are
to be taken out and what information
to delete at this specific timestamp.
Same as the forget gate in lstm, this functionality is same
as the forget gate in LST.
So, uh, suppose I have
input xts there
and the, the hidden state, uh, uh, information is there
and both are combined to get the, um,
that what is this RT information,
which is coming here, which is sigal.
Uh, this one you take input gate
and state their, their links are weight matrices
and there's somebody here
and po it through a Sigma Dell network.
And the output is called as the rt.
That is a reset gate output. Okay?
So, and this is
how the reset gate output is computed is essentially,
you know, same as your LST immune,
the variables are different.
Um, so here I will go back to this figure.
I think it's more, uh, clear compared to as we compare,
I take HT minus one, XT minus one
and combine them, pass it through a sigma.
That is this rt.
The how that RT is computed, uh,
that is shown in an expanded manner there.
This RT is multiplied with HT minus one, uh, to
take it as no how, what is to be forgotten
and what is to be retained.
And that information gets added with xt.
Again, it's a summation of that
with the respective weight metrics.
And that will be, you know, taken further positive
through a hyperbolic to generate the current state, uh,
information HT minus one, okay?
And then the same
HT minus one long-term information is uh, multiplied a year
and then somewhat with this state to get the
what is passed on to the uh, next state.
So that is how it is there.
And this RT part only shown here, this rt,
how it is computed here, uh, in this figure,
how this RT is computed.
That logic is shown here.
Uh, you don't worry about this part,
you only worry about HT minus one is there, XT is there.
You combine together, pass it
through a sigal network to get rt.
That is a reset gate output.
Once you get that reset data output, you multiply with that
to get the, you don't worry about this ZT part now I'm just
only telling about the RT part.
So update gate.
So, uh, again, I take HT minus one input XT added
and pass it through as Z gate.
It is same as whatever the RT gate was coming,
but this is weight metrics are different.
That's how this zat is coming shown in a different color.
But otherwise, if you see now both zat
and rt, if you see, uh, both are somewhat
with the only differences,
the respective weight metrics are different.
So accordingly, the, the RT
and ZAT values will be different.
RT is for reset and ZT is for the update gate. Okay?
These are the way I will compute each of the gate outputs
once I get the gate output.
Now you see, so first thing is reset gate output,
how I am computing, which is same as your forget gate.
Then how do you compute the update gate?
Now let us see this update gate, this update gate,
whatever the IT or OT we were telling.
And uh, this update gate, what is nothing
but you combine pass it through a SIG model.
And that is nothing but ZT here. That is the zt.
What we have, because that is applied directly to HT uh,
computation the po.
And that's why this is the update gate, uh, our output gate.
And I am deriving the input gate
through the same as one minus of that.
Okay? So that is the, uh, thing.
So gate then
after that I want to compute hidden state vector
that captures information from past times, steps relevant
to the current times, which is different dimension
of state will carry weighted values of STC and LTC.
This the most important statement here.
So in the case of LSTM, we were keeping two lines separately
for LTC and STC, then how does
here you keep both LTC and STC in only one line?
This statement, the same vector.
Some dimensions are reserved
for long-term context information.
for short-term context information
and those respective dimensions are, um,
manipulated by the reset.
And three, so that's what it'll happen.
Now, earlier I explained how RT is computed
and ZT is computed.
RT is for reset the state.
That reset happens and ZT is for the update.
And, uh, this reset one is now here, this line,
if you see, um, the summation of that is coming
to this point through that, uh,
sigmoidal gate output.
And that gets, uh, now added here
and pository hyperbolic function to get the new candidate
for HT r.
Let us go to this part.
So here, uh,
the sigmoidal that I'm computing, zet,
which I'm computing here, the zet,
and if you see, know, the reset gate output
is added with the XT to get this
weighted and added version of that that passes
through T hyperbolic function.
This path we have to see that is multiplied with
the, uh, update gate to get that final out.
So accordingly, um,
if you see here, so the recent get output multiplies
this HT minus one to get this candidate here.
That is somewhat with, uh, uh, whatever the, um,
input xt, I have to see this,
this is a confusion in the line here.
And this tam hyperbolic, this output is coming.
The some value is passing through it and hyperbolic,
and the, this part is
multiplied here for the ht.
That confusion is
This HT dash is coming.
I think this is multiply with that
and think they should be into symbol plus symbol
and not timely, not able to see that.
Maybe I look into that.
And so now this combined value poit
through the portfolio function to get this HD value,
the current state value.
And then now finally, uh,
what you get is this HT minus one is multiplied by
this ZT to get that.
And this HT candidate, you got it.
And this is multiplied by one minus ZT
into ht, uh, this one.
So whatever this ZT is there, one minus
of zat, that is nothing bad here.
If you see, you know, that one
minus of that zat.
So that is what, uh, uh, is given here, one minus of zat
and that is multiplied with the ST value.
Uh, one minus is a T to HT dash.
And this is combined with the TT HT minus one
to get the final hd.
That is how they define final HD value is nothing
but thet to HT minus one
and one minus of ZT to HT star.
So how it is, for example here, if you see
whatever zt, the one minus of ZT into HT minus one,
then here ZT two HT dash that added
with this, that will be the final
output that you're going get.
So that is how it is been now,
uh, computed here.
Um, finally, um, with the same
of course, um, the important point here is
that HD vector will,
some dimensions will have long term context information
and some dimensions will have short term
context information.
So with that respective dimensions will be weighted
by this Z tier one minus sft.
So that's how it is there.
And then for example, the,
if you see here, um, the HT that we are going to compute,
which is coming out of this place is, see,
before that I computed the air
and um, uh, I've updated long-term context information,
po it through a hyperbole function multiplied
with the output gate to get this HD value.
And the same process is done,
but in a different fashion in the GRU case.
Finally, what you get, this HT here will be output, same
as when you are getting through the LS tm.
Only thing is the, the, the, uh, comparing
that only this one minus rt,
all those operations have been done.
Um, so just to summarize,
the recent gate output is same as the,
um, forget gate thing.
What we had. And this update gate is same as the
output gate that we studied in LSTM
and this one minus ZT is nothing,
but that is same as the input gate.
That is same as the input gate.
So that is how, if it is one minus zt, same
as the input gate, and this is the output gate.
Okay? And uh, so
accordingly, output gate is multiplied with that.
Um, uh, these are T output.
That's how the TH minus T comes
and the standard hyperbolic output function,
multiply one minus T, which is nothing but the input gate.
If you see though there is a 10 hyperbolic, it's going
to the output line.
And that is nothing but here, sorry.
So here, this T hyperbolic function, going to
that output line, those dimensions are handled here.
In this case, this ht, those dimension LIC function,
which is going to multiplied by the input gate,
that is one minus zt.
And that finally you combine them
to get the final statement.
So that is how the, uh, GRU will take care,
even though this looks more complex.
Um, maybe when you get time, you can go through
carefully analyze if you, if you want to analyze,
this is the final diagram.
If you see this final diagram
and see the signal flow that is happening here,
you can carefully map into
all the different stage outputs in the L sst.
So then no, it'll be, uh, you'll realize that it is same
as LS team, except
that we are reduced the one gate and one line.
I think that is what I wanted to say.
Maybe if there is any question I will
take, otherwise I'll stop.
Yeah,
Sir. In, in
terms of, uh, computational costs, which is better,
like, uh, GU
Is better, GRU is better.
GRU is better. Yeah, only, you know, one neural network.
I'm removing just one neural network
that input gate neural network.
I'm removing, I'm the no update gate itself.
Uh, output gate itself, I will do as both input gate
and the output gate.
So that is how that reduces the,
and also the line, no memory line that also I'm reducing.
So from that point of view, it reduces this one, but maybe
So it'll be optimum for any kind of data
or any kind of sequential data, uh, specific.
It's optimal. It's optimal. There's no pro problem there.
It also captures that long-term context information
and things.
So actually maybe there may be some literature, Sunil,
maybe knowing that, uh, actually if you see,
uh, initially RNN was there when they found
there is a problem in, um,
modeling the long-term context information.
They propose that it is GRU first,
then they told Nene one line, uh,
you are complicated some dimensions you're keeping
for short term context information, some dimensions,
you long-term information, why can't aggregate them?
It'll become simplified view.
That is how they move on to LS team.
But LS team becomes so prevalent
that now people now mostly use LS team only.
They don't really care for this competition part that much.
Okay? But as an historical importance, you want to compare,
you can study that GR report.
Sure, thank you. Okay, thank you.
Okay, Sunil? Yes,
Sir, thank you.
Okay, so, so I'll also, uh, uh,
repeat the concept of GRU itself to give you some,
uh, other perspective.
Miss, uh, uh, I'll, I'll take you through numerical examples
to have some, some understanding that the, how exactly the,
these calculation multiplication additions had just
explained is happening as well as some, some, uh,
the pictorial view so
that you may understand it in a better way.
So, uh, the point is that we dis we were discussing
as a limitation of the RNN if you can recall that
whenever the context is long, that time the RNN suffers
because it, it has difficulty for,
for the longer context, right?
And that's how L-S-T-M-V alert the same thing,
same motivation is true for the GRU as well.
So now say that we have an example
where it is written as this one.
The generative AI can generate new content, okay?
So when we read this particular sentence, suppose we
have never, uh, gone into the detail
of generative AI for the first time.
Suppose we are reading, so we'll get some,
some new information that, okay?
There is a field called generative ai
and it is meant to generate the new content.
Next line says that generative AI is
a type of deep learning.
So when you read the second sentence, what happened,
that there are certain information which you have already
understood, like say that generative ai, okay?
Now the same thing. This particular term at least is being
repetitive even in the second sentence, generative ai.
So maybe there is no gain, right? Okay.
So by seeing these token generative or the next token ai,
because that is how we process it in the time
stamp manner, right?
So you may not, uh,
you may not add anything into your existing memory.
That is how it happens. So you just recall we were doing the
four gate, and in the input gate we were adding
some new information.
So maybe by looking into generative, I don't want to, uh,
obviously, uh, I don't want
to forget anything also in my memory
because generative is something which is already there in my
memory as well.
I, as well as I don't want to add also anything.
This is something which I already have in my
memory and I don't want to add.
Same thing. The LS TM will work when it comes
to the deep learning, generative
ai, the type of deep learning.
This is something which is interesting in this sentence,
which was not there in my first sentence, deep learning.
So maybe this is the new information which I want to add.
Uh, when, where in, in this part,
when I'll process this particular sentence.
So this deep and this learning,
these two words are important.
But you see this third sentence again,
it is like deep learning is a subset
of neural networks, maybe deep learning.
I have already understood it.
It is as it is a type, uh,
genetic AI is a type of deep learning.
But now, so this deep
and learning these two tokens may not be of interest
of mine, and I'll not add in the memory cell.
I'll not do any update, right?
But when it comes to deep learning,
it's a subset of neural networks.
Again, if there is a new information which is coming
as neural and networks
and that, that, I would like to add one to two, some kind
of, uh, context
because this is how we are, uh, like, uh,
going generative AI to deep learning,
deep learning to neural network.
And that is the context we want to preserve
and hence will add some new
information based on these two words.
And finally, neural network is a part of machine learning.
Again, neural network is not that much important here,
but this machine learning, maybe this is important.
Learning is also we have seen,
but machine learning, maybe this machine
and learning together, that is
what we are going to compare to deep learning.
That is how we update the memory. So that is the c.
So in the LS tm, when we say that there is a four gate gate,
um, out or input gate or put gate.
So this is what we do when we see the next context,
we try to forget something.
We, we try to add some new information.
That is how we update the, the overall memory. Okay?
So now same thing. The GRU also does. Okay?
The RE also try to uh, have the, uh, the logic is same,
that it is also, uh, try to model that what
to remember from the past, what to forget
and what new information to add.
Okay? This is what is essentially, uh, the work
of LSTM and GRU.
Fine. Now, you have seen already that, uh, the diagram
of a single GRU cell, okay?
For a single timestamp, right?
Where you have the input xt, okay?
And uh, then you had the last hidden state
or output, ST minus one rt.
We set it as reset gate zt, we it as update gate
and ST til that is what we are seeing as candidate head
and state, and ST is my final head and state.
So if I'll take you back, uh,
or I can, uh, just show you here, this is
what you have just seen.
So if you see that in the GRU,
we have obviously reduced the complexity
by removing one of the gait.
So now we have only these three neural network.
You can see that last time in the L we are having
four neural networks.
So at least one, one layer, one layer
of complexity we have reduced.
Okay? So it is less complex in that sense.
Now, there is another change.
What you can observe here is there is no separate line
for the CT and h st ct and HT is same here.
When the, that the main, main memory
and the short term memory
and the long-term memory, both are same.
And that is what is represented by hd.
And there is more, uh, I guess you can say intuitive
because just think about our own brain, human brain, I mean,
uh, everything is a memory, right?
Whether it is a short term or long term fine.
So we don't have a separate, uh, layers where I can say, oh,
this is my short term, this is my long term.
But everything is a memory, something exercise,
a short term, some, some,
some memory is my, our long term memory.
So in the same sense, the, are you what it says
that this line, this line is my memory.
Now with this same line,
I will maintain the short term context
also and long term context.
So now that was not the case in the LS team, right?
So LSTM said that, okay,
my long-term main memory is different
and my short term, uh,
with this hd I'm maintaining separately.
Okay? So there is another change in that, that sense.
You can see that. Now overall objective,
if you will see in the GRU overall objective,
then I'll go into the detail as well.
Overall objective is this one.
What you're seeing here, it's a two step.
You can see two step or two a stage process.
So you have the, uh, you can say that the old memory, okay?
Now, based on the new information
or the current state input, you first find the candidate,
um, candidate hidden state.
That is what this is the previous time hit state.
So, so far, so that till this
particular point, I have a memory.
That memory I'm representing at ST minus one.
Now when I am processing the information, okay,
now at this particular time stamp, now with respect to
that time stamp and whatever previous memory I have, I say
that this should be my new memory, st dash
or tilt, whatever you say, this should be my new memory.
That is what I have computed.
This is the computation, which I have done.
This is my previous memory,
this is my new memory based on the current input.
But obviously you can't rely on this computation completely,
a hundred percent, okay?
You can say that for example, just, just imagine this one,
something is like, uh, we are watching one movie
or some web series where there is a thriller,
there is a suspense and so on.
And maybe initially it shows that there is,
there is a person who was, who is projected to be killer,
and suddenly there is a plot change.
And we saw that, okay, there is a new killer, right?
So what happens basically based on the current information,
now we may have the sumption, oh,
this new person might be a killer,
but I can can't rely on that, right?
There are, there were some previous context also
this person right now in the movie showing
or being projected as a killer.
But there is a chance that that will again,
change with some more context.
So ST is a candidate head in state.
It is not the one which I have to rely a hundred percent.
So what we are trying to do is somehow from my old memory,
I'm first creating the candidate new memory.
That new memory may be looking like that where person B
is said to be the killer,
but I can't rely on that information only.
Maybe there might be some other, uh,
other suspense which is not yet revealed.
So what we do, we do some kind of balancing, balancing
between, okay, what I have seen so far,
what I'm getting now, let us balance these two.
And that is what is your hd? Okay?
So this is a two stage process.
Again, what what we are doing is st minus one,
this is the one with which I start
that I'm saying this is my memory.
Somehow I compute in between st tilt, okay?
Using this reset gate
and update gate, I, I say that my memory so far was a,
but I'm saying now based on the current information xt,
I'm saying my memory should be B,
but somehow I can't rely on B completely.
I can't be, I can can't ignore A and keep B as it is.
So that I'll balance between A and B
and I'll make it as a memory, which is called C.
Okay? So this, this is just three there.
You can say the memory, which is, which is the next form.
Uh, you can say that the memory based on the current
information, what we are updating, okay?
Those are, you can understand, right?
So just to simplify, I'm saying this one,
you can treat the GRUA two stage process, okay?
Start with some memory first, find
what can be the candidate new memory that, okay,
my memory should be represented at st tilt, but st tilt
and st minus one.
Now at this stage, I have two different types
of the old memory and the new memory st tilt.
So I let, let me balance between these two, keep some aspect
of ST minus one.
Also some aspect
of st tiled also create an altogether new memory
that is called st.
And this we do at every time stamp, okay?
For, for that particular sequence, what we are processing,
and then for the next sequence also, okay?
So this is the overall, you can understand it like that.
Now, now if you see how to, how we are doing this one,
how we are doing this one, okay?
How we first find the candidate, uh, candidate,
candidate hidden state,
and then from the candidate hidden estate, we find the
new hidden estate St.
Okay, now this is what that is,
what is the story we have to understand?
So basically what we are doing is, as I said,
there is something, some, some assumption about a person A,
that he might be a killer.
But based on the new information, we have
to first reset our memory here.
RT is acting as a reset, reset gate.
So what we are doing is some new context has come
and we may have to reset our memory.
We, because we have seen little more com, uh,
little more context, new scenes has come in the movie.
And now it says that no, there is a chance
that person B can also be the memory.
So maybe I have to Fargo
or for forget some of the things
what I have already seen here.
So I'm just resetting amur.
It is similar to what Fargate get you have done.
Uh, in the case of that, uh, uh, LSTM, okay?
Now based on this resetted memory, resetted memory
and xt, then we calculate the the candidate memory.
The candidate memory, okay? The hd, okay, HD Now.
So resetted memory and XD together form the candidate
memory St tilt.
And then we do the balancing between st and st minus one.
Okay? Using this upgrade ticket,
the balancing is being done here, okay?
So the two step, what I was talking, so I can, if I,
so one step is happening here.
Uh, I'm sorry, not here.
Uh, okay,
so one step is happening here.
So where from st minus one, I'm calculating this st til
and st til how I'm calculating.
So if you see this particular line, it is coming from here.
Okay? So this line, okay, so this operation I'm doing,
which is a reset gate,
and once HT tool is calculated from there,
I'm just doing this much operation,
this much operation to get the hd.
To get the hd, okay?
So this is how you can, uh, break down
and now I'll further break down it, okay?
So that, uh, let us understand what is happening.
So I guess you can understand two things that
why the sequence, uh,
preserving the sequence information is important, right?
Because when I gave this another example
that initially we had the generative AI just as a projection
of new content generator.
Well, later I said that it is a type of deep learning later,
I said that deep learning is neural network.
So somehow we are updating
or resetting our memory, resetting in the sense,
some things I have to keep
and some, some, some of the things I have to keep here
that generative AI is same as generat.
I I have to keep some of the aspects here, right?
Some more things I have to just, uh, forget. Okay?
So that is what I decide.
That is what I decide with this RT reset gate, that
what I took keep what I to forget.
So somehow we are trying to preserve that part here. Okay?
So how does, and then, then, uh, let us, let us see that.
How does this happen? So first of all, say that I have two.
So I, as as it is true for any kind of RN network,
as each time a stamp, you have two inputs.
The current current input that is xt
and last here in a state output, that is XT minus one,
two inputs at each time stamp, okay?
And this is whole projection is
for the particular time stamp.
For every time stamp, these whole things will happen. Okay?
So now let us see that XT is your one of the input
and ST minus one is another input, okay?
ST minus one is the lasted and state input, another input.
Now what is happening is together. Together.
So what happened that xt, you see this one?
It is going from here, okay?
It is going from here
and st minus one, it is coming from here together.
These two, these two till here,
and then it goes here, okay?
This, this particular neural network,
this particular neural network
and that, that will give me the rt,
that will give me the rt.
You can see here rt. But these,
this is the line which I'm following right now.
So what will happen as it is a neural network,
and here you will have say that four neurons, just
for the example, four neurons.
So this RT will be a vector.
Uh, one more thing I said earlier also in the case of lstm,
this ST minus one, this rt, zt, ST
and st, all these are vectors.
Even XT is a vector.
But other than xt, all,
all these vectors have the same dimension.
That is what you have to remember.
You can't have the varying dimension for this RT from ZT
or ZT from tt, no.
If you plan to keep four neurons here,
you will have four neurons here also.
And you will have four neurons here also.
So if you have four neurons here, you will get a vector
as an output where you'll have four output, a vector
with four values here also here, also here also, so
that when you do the pointwise multiplication anywhere
or pointwise addition, anywhere you can do the pointwise.
Otherwise pointwise you can't do if you don't have the same
dimensional vector, right?
And that's why by default, once you decide to keep the, uh,
once you decide to keep this, uh, neuron four,
the 4, 4 4 will be true for all the cases.
That's why dimension of all these vectors are same,
except xt, except XT can also be four.
But it is not depending on other, other, other vector
that we discussed in the previous classes.
Right? Now let us, uh, go ahead.
So first of all, I said that, uh, I said that first of all,
we'll start with here, okay?
S st minus one, I will come and xt I will come
and then I will pass it to sig mite.
So sig mite will always result in a, in a vector, uh, in a,
in a vector and vector value will be always like
between zero to one, okay?
It'll be between 0 2 1, okay?
So what will happen, whatever is fee,
the ST is also coming from here.
You can see that, right? This is also
vector of the same dimension.
What this RT is giving.
Now, say that the first vector here is some, some values
and the vector, what I'm getting is some
value between zero and one.
And what we are doing here is pointwise multiplication.
You see this particular part,
pointwise multiplication, okay?
Once we get this RT,
then we do this operation pointwise multiplication.
So obviously if suppose it is zero,
the corresponding element here,
whatever vector will get, becomes zero.
It suppose it is one
that's corresponding element here will be as it is.
And if it is between zero
and one, so that much amount of information we will forget
that much amount of information will forget.
So, um, to give you a better, uh, understanding
of all these things, let me just show you the numbers
as well so that you will understand it side by side.
Just a second. So basically just,
just imagine my XT is three dimensional vector xt,
the three dimensional vector, 0.6, 0.2, 0.9, some embedding
because every word I did token, I'm representing
as agile embedding say this is the embedding.
And st minus one,
which is the lasted in state output is
like four dimensional vector.
So this is 0.4, 0.7, 0.1, 0.8.
So what I said, first of all, you do this operation,
you pin the rt.
RT is nothing but the weighted sum plus bias.
So XD will get multiplied with one set of weight,
ST minus one will get multiplied with another set of weight.
You will add the bias. Suppose that is coming at zar,
this is the linear output, this weighted simple bias
and that we are applying on sigmoid.
So sigmoid output will be between zero and one.
So what you are doing here is you are point
for point the point wise multiplication between RT
and S st minus one.
This is the same operation which I was showing here, here,
or this is the same operation which I am trying to show, uh,
sorry, which I'm trying to show,
okay?
Which I'm, which, uh, I'm trying to show here.
This one, this particular operation, okay?
This is the same operation.
So now you can imagine that these, this is also a vector.
This is also a vector and you will do the
0.1 multiplication.
And because this, uh, this RT will result always
between zero and one.
So whatever vector you have here, you have
to do the 0.1 multiplication.
And you're saying that, say that, uh, say that you have now,
just imagine that you have the vector,
like st minus one RT minus one.
Like, uh, okay,
just a second like this.
So what you're doing is you are saying that say
that this is the r rt, what we are getting 0.43,
0.69, zero point.
So between zero and one sig y, right?
So it'll always give between zero and one and st minus one.
We have already decided that this is the st minus one.
Suppose we have, what we'll do, this is 0.4.
So RT will decide whether you want to keep 0.4 as 0.4
or you want to reduce it.
You want to forget some of the aspect of this 0.4.
Similarly, you want to keep this 0.7 as it is,
or you want to forget some of the aspect
or you want to forget it completely.
So suppose now the, the first time engineer 0.43.
So this 0.43 will get multiplied with 0.4
and that should result you in, in the, the, so
what we are saying is if it is 0.4, I'm saying that only
40% of this particular component should be remembered.
Okay? I'm saying that one 40%
of this component should be remembered.
Similarly, if suppose it is 0.6, I'm saying that only, uh,
I'm saying that uh, 0.69%
of this 0.7 should be remembered, okay?
And here 0.48, right?
That means I'm saying that 0.48%
of this 0.1 should be remembered.
And that is what you can see, observe here.
That next value is accordingly, like that itself 0.43
and 2.4, it is almost 0.17.
So now what has happened is my ST minus one was 0.4.
Now after reset get, I'm only remembering 0.1, seven,
0.4 is now being represented at 0.17.
So I have almost forgotten rest 60% of the things
of this particular dimension.
Similarly, I have forgotten 0.7. Now it is 0.48.
So I've forgotten some of the aspect
of the second dimension Also, third dimension was, sorry,
it is 0.1, 0.1, right?
So now I have only 0.05,
almost 50% I have forgotten, okay?
And here I have 0.5, now I have 0.38,
almost 77% I have forgotten.
So this is telling that how much you have to forget.
So that is what is this first part in this, in this, uh, rt.
So after that, what will happen is,
now I guess you have understood that
what will come from here
after this point, what is going to come, okay?
Now this is done.
So this part we have done, so this part we have done. Okay?
So we have decided that
how much we have reset it about memory, no, that is done.
Now, what we have to do is first, once this is done, that,
okay, how much we have then first of all we have
to calculate this st till, st till
and how we are calculating st till, you'll see that
whatever you have got the output from this, uh,
got the output from this, uh, uh, what is
that reset gate, okay?
The vector, which I was showing you
after the forgetting, that will again get multi, uh,
that will again get uh, the input from the xt.
So you see this one, I'll just show you in the figure.
So this is my reset gate vector.
And you see this one here, this is, and there is a gap.
So actually it is coming here.
So the same vector along with the xt, along
with this xt, okay?
Along with this xt. So this XT is also a
vector and reset gate.
After the reset gate, what pointwise, multiplication,
whatever we are getting that is also a vector.
And that is this vector and XT is this vector. Okay?
Now these two vector together, together,
these two vector comes here to this standard.
Now see we are here in the, at the 10 inch.
This is also neural network with the four neurons
because we decided
to keep 4, 4, 4 neurons at all the places.
And that is what, uh, uh, this, this together,
what it'll do, it'll do this particular equation.
You see this equation, the 10 inch, what it will do again,
weighted some plus bias.
So you have two types of input.
First one is the resetted gate output and another one is xd.
You have the weight, you do the linear computation
and pass it through the tage.
And this one I'm saying as my candidate, uh,
hidden estate output,
my candidate candidate in the sense this is this,
this is going to be probably the next, next,
next hidden estate, what I want
to create next, hidden estate.
Next memory, I want to create as detailed.
I want to create at as detailed, okay?
The next here, estate.
Now, uh, uh, now, uh,
so what, what is happening is, so why I say
that next candidate here estate.
You can understand this one
that there is a logic behind that.
See, I have my current input as XT
and I have already decided what to keep
and what to using this RT into s st minus one.
I have already decided that.
So based on that one, what can be my next memory
that I'm preparing as ST tilt?
So that is what is this st tilt here. Okay?
That's why I say it's a candidate new hidden estate, okay?
But I said I can't rely on this completely, okay?
I can't rely on this completely.
And hence I have the other things which I com compute using
the update kit, this chat chat part,
I'm saying it as a update kit.
This whole part, this whole part, okay,
how do we compute once I have this candidate
cell st tilt ready?
Then I first calculate this, uh, uh, zet, zt,
uh, which which we say it as a, you can say it as a,
um, as an update kit.
Okay? So what, what it is doing ZT
and rt, in a way it is same, right?
Because you can see the input, right?
Xt, xt, XT minus one, it's the same input.
So if I draw it for you, it'll be something like that.
So basically my XT is going
and ST minus one is coming here, follow the blue line
and then together it goes to this zt,
this particular neuron, this neuron.
So in a way the input is same.
All these differences here, the weight metrics says WWZ.
Here the made weight metrics is WR, okay?
So weight is different, otherwise it is same,
otherwise it is same.
So now you can see that I will again explain you that
what we do do is we have already calculated this rd.
We have already calculated this st.
So this whole part is done.
This whole part we have done, okay, this is done.
Now we are left with only this much calculation.
What we are doing is first of all, we are calculating now ZT
and zt we are calculating in the same way.
It'll be also give me the vector
and whose value will be between zero
and one like RT has given.
Okay? So now what we are doing is we are trying to,
as I said, we have to do the balance between, okay,
new memory is st tilt, old memory st minus one.
So let us make a balance between them.
Let us decide how much st minus one weight I have to give
and how much weight to give for this hd.
That is what we decide in this, in this operation.
So now you can see the last equation.
We say that one minus ZT. So ZT is a vector.
Remember between zero and one, between zero
and one into st minus one.
So this, this, this is for the first parties that
ST minus it gets multiplied with ST minus one,
seest minus one is here and s st tilt is here.
S st tilt is my new candidate memory
and S st minus one is the old memory.
And what we are doing is both this part we are multiplying
with one component and this is called weights.
I'm giving some weights to ST minus one also
I'm giving some weights to SD also.
And then combining them together to decide
what should be my new HD for the next time stamp.
So what is happening here?
How we are giving the weight, let us see that.
Now say that my zeti ZT is a vector,
ZT is a vector.
So between, so that is a vector you can just,
just imagine it'll be like 0.1
or it can be one also it can be zero also it can be 0.9.
Also all these values are possible
because it is a sig white output.
So it, it can be anything.
So now just see that suppose this particular ZT is
one extreme cases.
What will happen? One minus 1 0 1 minus one zero means zero
into ST minus one means we are giving zero weight
to our old memory.
And if it is one, then this ZT will be one.
We are giving, giving full control
to this st the new candidate memory,
which we have just prepared.
Now, on the other hand, on the other hand, suppose my uh,
ZT zero, okay?
Then what we are giving one minus zero is one,
we are giving whole control to the old memory
and we are giving zero control
because that T zero to the new candidate's
memory what we have prepared.
Okay? And on the third case, third case like in between.
So maybe suppose that T 0.5, so what will happen?
Point five will come here. Mono minus 0.5 is 0.5.
Point five weight I'm giving for HT minus one and ZT is 0.5.
So 0.5 weight also I'm giving for the new candidate memory.
So you see that this line, last line is actually a balancing
that, okay, how much earlier memory I have to retain
and how much new can new memory, which I have just created
that I have to add.
Okay? And that is what we are doing here. Okay?
So that is why this, this, this, this whole operation
and now you will understand it very easily.
So what is happening is we are, first
of all whatever is zeti based on
that we are doing one minus zeti.
So one minus Z is written here.
That's why it is one minus point twice.
So if it is a vector for every component
we'll do one minus ZT.
But that is getting multiplied.
That is getting multiplied with what?
With this ST minus one.
That's why it is one minus ZT into st minus one. Okay?
Now going forward there is a plus.
So there is a plus here, there is a plus here.
And you see that ZT is also coming in
this direction, in this diagram.
So ZT is here and first it is getting multiplied 0.1
multiplication with HT tilt that is happening here
and then it is being added to this particular component.
That's why this whole thing together,
whole thing together, okay?
You can represent it, you can represent it
with this particular equation, whereas you're computing
with this particular line
and everything can be represented by this mathematical flow.
Okay? So I'll summarize, okay?
So what is happening basically
that this ZRU is a two stage operation.
So from the old memory st minus one,
I create the new candidate memory
and from the new candidate memory by giving weight
for the old memory, also new candidate memory.
Also I create the s st. Now how do we do that?
So first of all, from old memory
to the new candidate memory,
when we are creating, who is helping?
RT is helping, RT is helping
to create the old memory ST minus one to the new memory st.
You can see that when you're creating this new candidate
memory, who is helping this component is help.
And what is this component? This rt?
Okay, RT is required anyway, ST minus one,
you already have xt, you already have
what you're computing in between rt.
So RT is important.
Now, in order to go from second stage, go from ST candidate
to ST who is helping, this T is helping
because once you have zt you can simply add, uh,
just place all the value here and then you get the st.
So it's a two step process, right?
And this is how it is placed
and they are connected to get, just update the memory.
Okay? Now let me know if you have any questions So far
There one comment that you explained it very nicely.
This slide says it all, sir. Very nice. Thank you sir.
Okay, thank you. Okay.
Still if you have any confusion, someone you can ask
It clear. So
Yeah, fine, thank you.
So now I was just showing you one more thing.
Uh, that one second, sorry.
So here all these things are same, uh,
I have just presented it like, uh,
xt ST minus one gives you RT
and then do the point while multiplication between RT
and ST minus one, right?
And that output
and XT will give you s st til the candidate memory.
And once you have the candidate memory, st til, first
of all you calculate the ZT from XT and ST minus one
and then you do the multiplication,
pointwise multiplication.
And then again you hear also the point management.
Finally you add them and then you get the final.
I've explained you that, that this is a stepwise diagram,
but this diagram, if you understand that how it is happening
with these, then I guess things will be clear.
Now I was just showing you the numerical example.
So XT and s st minus one, you can treat it as a vector
and their dimension can be different,
but all other dimension has to be same.
ST minus one, rt, zt, zar, everything is, it will be
have the same dimension.
Four. I decided to start with four.
So I have to keep all the dimension as four.
Okay, so here I also explained that how you are just, uh,
calculating all these
and just, uh, getting the value for RT first.
And from rt you're doing the point wise multiplication
with the previous time a hidden state vector, get the, uh,
you can see the resetted output, which is this one.
And then you calculate the candidate, uh, sell. Okay?
Again, I have shown some examples to make it more clear.
And finally the, the calculating the HD HD is nothing
but the balance balancing out between st minus one,
which is my last year in estate output, last memory.
Okay? And st can, st til is my current state memory.
So let us balance out how much, how much weight I have
to give to s st minus one, how much, uh, weight I have
to give to the current memory and balance out
and get the final s st which we'll pass
to the next time step.
Okay? This is what is the GRU in a nutshell? That else?
So, uh, this is the final slide maybe
before we'll go to the next.
So we say that memory update is additive, uh, in the,
the GRU, why it works better as compared to RNN.
It is not as compared to a Tian, uh,
memory update is additive, not purely multiplicative, uh,
uh, and it, it matters a lot.
I'll say you, it matters a lot
because what is happening here is,
if I'll go back again in the diagram, what is,
what is happening is we are transforming from st minus one
to st in between we are calculating the candidate memory.
But ultimately what is happening is we have a, uh,
we have some additive operation, which we do in between
to transform from ST minus one to st.
That is, this is the additive operation I'm
talking about, okay?
Right. So, but then in the case of rn,
and if you can recall, there was no addition.
There was always multiplication,
multiplication, multiplication.
At each time stem, there was a multiplication.
Everywhere there is a multiplication.
Now you can under understand why this is better,
why it'll not, it'll be less, uh, prune to the, uh,
vanishing gradient and why RNN was, uh, uh, more likely
to go to the vanishing gradient
because there in the RN there was nowhere, this,
this, uh, this operation additive operation,
we were doing multiplication.
So 0.1 here, there is a chance that it'll get added
with some value and it'll not go towards the zero.
But in the RN there was no such chances.
You have to multiply all the gradient when you go down into
the timestamp and do the back propagation, right?
So that's why it's very important
that here we don't do only the multiplication.
It is, uh, the memory update is additive,
not purely multiplicative.
Okay? That is, that is very important.
Gates controls the information flow it decide that what
to retain, what, what to fargate, all those things, okay?
Which was not there. Again,
in the RNN gradients, do not vanish quickly.
As I said, long-term dependencies are preserved. Okay?
So this is what, uh, how you compare
and also said that if you compare ZRU
and LSTM, I said in the earlier class also,
ZRU is less complex.
Why? Because you are using only two gates,
reset gate and update gate.
And hence corresponding weights are lesser
as compared to the STM.
Okay? There you need three different set of mattresses here.
You need just two set of mattresses, okay?
So it ultimately the parameters, uh,
through which I'm comparing
that which one is less complex or more complex.
So GRU has the lesser number of parameter,
hence it is less complex.
And if you talk about the power wise, who is powerful,
as I said, GRU and LST most, and,
and most of the time they may perform
almost at the same level.
Okay? There might be a significant performance gap
between GRU and L lstm most of the time, okay?
But still you can prefer GRU
because it, it it is less complex.
Okay? That is, that is how it might be even a preference.
But, uh, LS tm, uh, LST LSTM is more popular
as compared to the ZRU, right?
Um, but power-wise, they are at the same level.
There is no, um, uh, there is uh, uh,
uh, there is no, uh, such, uh, evidence.
We say that KGRU is, uh,
really better than not performal estimate
and something like that, okay?
Little variance you may see,
but it'll be almost at the same level.
If you'll have the enough data, enough training,
if you will do, they will be at the same level.
Okay? Yeah.
So, uh, uh, this is what we have from this,
this video point of view.
Now, uh, if you have further any question you can ask us,
otherwise we'll move to the next, uh, topic.
So as I see now, we are in the first week, uh,
so at roughly six to seven classes we are left with.
So we have anyway completed the rn
and now we will go a little deep into the RN and,
and we have this sequence to sequence modeling
and attention on top of the sequence to sequence modeling.
That is what he's yet to be covered, which we will,
I guess we will be able to cover in six to seven classes,
which we have to take, okay?
So you have any question you can ask us.
Now, uh, demo wise, if you'll ask me,
there is no change in the sense if you,
I will just project my, so
that's why I'm not showing you any separate demo
for this GRU.
Uh, but that is not required.
Now you just have to do the practice.
Um, so GRU by it is same
as the lstm, what we have already discussed.
I here you can see that, right?
So it is also in the, uh,
and in module of the torch by torch
and instead of LSTM, we just have to use the GRU, okay?
Otherwise, everything is same. Everything.
You don't have to change in the code internal, all the uh,
means, uh, equations, you know, how does it work?
You know? So only while calling, you have
to use the GRU instead of LS tm
and it'll work in the same way.
There is no change. You can try the same, uh,
uh, what is that next word?
Prediction task. What we have seen in the case of the LSTM,
you can now try with the GRU as well.
Okay? Yeah.
So any question?
So one question. Yes.
So I performed one experiment with LSTM and GRU.
So I got the same results, uh, with both of them. Mm-hmm.
The dataset size was around 50,000 samples.
So I just want to understand,
will there be any difference in the accuracy
or the performance?
Uh, if I increase the data set,
I just said, um, right power wise,
theoretically there should be no difference, okay?
Because both of the network are trying to do the same thing.
Somehow. They want to update their memory by using some
of the gates and retain the long context and short context.
This is the philosophy,
and this is true for both the networks.
So ideally there should not be any difference,
and power wise, there is no difference between these two.
No one is powerful than other complexity wise.
GRU is less complex
because of the, this number of gates, less number
of neural networks, less number of weights.
Now, as you have already checked with the 50,000 data
and you don't see any change, that is what, uh, it, it,
it proves it that yeah, power-wise there is no difference.
And your question is, now if I increase the data,
will there be any change?
I believe you can, although try,
and there is no definite answer for all these things.
I believe increasing data will not show you any change,
but if you decrease the data, okay, from 50,000,
you do it only for 5,000.
There you might see some change, okay?
Because the data is not sufficient.
Maybe one could understand it a little quicker way
and other just will take little more time, right?
And there you might see that, okay, one is getting, uh, uh,
having more performance than other,
there is a possibility of that.
But as you'll have more data already, you have seen
that 50,000 is enough data points.
So I don't see there much.
There will be any chance you can also try it and check,
Yeah, okay? So, so
if there's any uh, much variance in the data, uh,
then only we see some difference. Yes,
Yes. Otherwise
there is no difference. Yeah.
Got it sir. Thank you.
Would sequence length difference would make any difference
between the area analysis. Yeah.
At least with among these two,
you won't see much difference even with the sequence length.
Okay? Uh, yeah, you try comparing with some other kind
of network like RN
and all, there might, you will see a lot of difference
or you try with the transformer
or with the attention sequence to there you'll see.
But JRU and STM, again, sequence length won't impact much.
Yeah. Among these two.
Thank you, sir. Yeah.
Okay. So, uh, alright,
so I I sir, are you there?
Is there check once
Otherwise, uh, maybe, uh, sir will take you
through the, in, in the next class.
I will take you through the deep parens, right?
Deep parens in the sense like in the A
and n, we had the first hidden layer,
then we had the second hidden layer,
then we had the third hidden layer,
finally we had the output layer, something like that, right?
But so far, whatever LSTM
or GRU architecture, so an architecture we have seen,
we saw it like only there is one uh, hidden layer.
And that there in the hidden layer,
either we can have the RNN or lithium or, or Z rdu.
That is how we have seen so far.
But that is not the case always.
Like in the a NN where you have the multiple, uh, um,
you may, you have the multiple, sorry,
here it's okay.
Like you have the multiple, uh, a NN um,
fully connected layer stacked on top of each other.
So firsted in layer, seconded in layer third L layer,
then output layer in the L lium.
Also, you can have one list lium, which is stacked on the,
on top of the, the lium layer,
and you can have as many layers as you want.
Okay? That is also possible.
So what we'll do is there are two concepts which is left
with these RNN networks.
The first one is the stacking of these lstm or RNN layers.
And we'll try to understand the intuition behind it
because network wise, architecture wise, uh, it is, it is,
it is going to work in the same fashion.
There won't be change. But what is the intuition
of stacking like in the case of n and ian,
and we were saying that, oh, first, like in the case
of CNNI guess you can understand from CNN better we say
that, okay, first layer of the CN understand the
features from the image and that, that, that is very, very,
uh, a high level feature.
Say that I will understand only the edges,
that there is one a vertically, there is one a horizontally,
there is one circle here, right?
So individual edges information, then next, next layer
of the CNN can connect some of those edges
to create some kind of shape.
Then next layer of the CNN can add, uh,
get you more abstract, uh, features can give you some shapes
of the object also
and so on in a similar fashion, what are the intuition
behind adding these RNN layers a way with RNN we are able to
preserve the context when we go timestamp wise manner.
Why the second layer or third layer of the RNN
or S-T-M-R-G-R-U in a stacked fashion is required.
What is the intuition behind it? We'll understand that.
Secondly, there is a concept of bidirectional RN, okay?
We say that, okay, so far we have seen
that there is a x no information flowing from
left to right.
So the first time stamp there is x,
not the next time stamp X one, X two
and going all the way up
to the last time stamp XI left to right.
We are preserving the context, right?
But bidirectional, RNN says
that you can also preserve the context from right
to left, okay?
Right to left. And many times it is beneficial as well.
Many times it is beneficial as well. Okay?
So there are some, some context which is coming in between,
say that X two and the this X two, this is word, right,
this X two word in, uh, uh, word, uh,
context depends on X node.
X one also depends on say X three, X four.
Also there is a possibility of that, okay?
So if you are not going in both the direction,
then maybe you're understanding one aspect of X two,
but losing the other aspect of X two.
So that's where bidirectional, uh,
understanding is also important.
We, we'll understand it in a little more way, uh,
a little better way in the next class.
Okay? So meanwhile, whatever, uh, the we are time left with,
I planned that I will take you through
some, uh, the next concept.
The next concept is the concept of this.
These two are still left
and we will cover that when we start.
We'll start that and we still have 10 minutes.
So I thought that I'll give you some understanding of,
because immediately after these rn,
and we'll move to the sequence
to sequence modeling sequence to sequence modeling.
Okay? So I thought that I'll introduce that today so
that slowly we will dive into the sequence
to sequence modeling also.
And I will give you the motivation that why this kind
of network people, uh, have come up with what,
what was the requirement?
What was the thought process?
So if you can recall when we started this RNN
or when we started the CNN, we,
we had the similar discussion.
We said that suppose we have the tabler kind of data, okay?
So tabler kind of data, then it is always good to go
with the a n network.
Why? Because in the tabler kind of data, each columns are,
say that they're not dependent on each other, right?
Role wise, there is no dependency column wise,
there's no dependency, right?
So in such cases, A and N can work, A
and n can do our job, no need to go
with the complex network like CNN or uh, RNN
or STM, like that fine.
But when it comes to the image data,
a NN is not doing the job.
That is what we said because in the image we want
to extract the special information means the, in an image,
maybe only in the middle part
or the, the, the pixels, the surrounding pixels.
The neighbor pixels are important to captures once,
but what we were doing in the case of a NN, we just had
to flatten the image and passing.
So that was the problem in the a NN when we are dealing
with the, when we were dealing with the image, right?
And hence we said that oh, CNN is doing, it's able
to process the image data in a better way as compared
to the a NN.
Now, later when we had this sequencer data, uh, data,
and mostly we have seen in the sense of text, right?
So again, we said that, okay,
sequence information is something which we can't process in
parallel, and there is no special kind
of features also maybe, right?
We just have to preserve the context and that context.
We can only understand if we can process these sequence like
I am going in a timestamp manner.
And hence the A NN
or CNN, both of them are not able, uh, not not built for
that in n way cannot process the
information in the time stamped manner.
It has to process everything in parallel.
CNN if you will try also, then also you will not be able
to preserve the context, okay?
Uh, because it has to convolve, it has to accept everything
as a matrix and it has to convolve, right?
So these were the issues.
So we came up with this RN network,
and that's where we understood RNN list team and uh, right,
but all the three types of data, I think the three types
of problem we were ha we were able
to handle well till this point of time.
But suddenly there is a new kind
of problem which has emerged,
and the problem is known as sequence
to sequence problem, sequence to sequence.
Problem is in the input also, you have a sequence
and the output also you have a sequence
as you can see on the screen.
Okay? Now this is a new problem, okay?
Although it looks like video or something,
which I have already seen because we have been doing this
kind of translation from one language to other language.
But actually, if you now look back
that whatever you have covered in the deep learning so far,
this kind of problem, you have never addressed.
This problem is very unique.
And this is challenging, more challenging problem as
compared to the other three problems, what we have seen.
Why, why? Because one sequence say that I'm going, first
of all, the sequence can, can have the variable length,
right, that we have anywhere addressed with RN, tm,
and all fine problem here is the output is also a sequence.
And that this sequence can also be a variable length.
And the bigger problem is the
input sequence length
and the output sequence length they may
match and they may not match.
Also, like here in the case of translation here,
we have only three words in English,
but we have here four words in Hindi.
So the sequence length here is not matching
with the sequence length in input.
So these were the problems.
Now, once we have the sequence to sequence problem,
one thing was very short because it is a sequential data,
then RNN will be suitable for that.
RN will be suitable for that.
But whatever RNN network we have seen so far,
what we have done, we are processing all the inputs,
getting the output at the last hidden state
and saying that what is the output?
Okay? That that is, that is what, uh, we have built
so far in RNN types.
I have introduced, I said that there is a possibility
of many to many kind of RNN networks.
And this is one such example for that
sequence to sequence modeling.
And very good use case is the machine translation,
where you have the input as a sequence
and output also as a sequence one language,
two other language, okay?
But this problem was not as simple as we have done so far
with the RNN solid S tm, RGRU.
Okay? So this was a little challenging problem, fine, uh,
because, uh, how, how do we come up with this architecture
that, that at the first time, that was, uh, that was,
that itself was a very, very, uh, you can say
that the unique contribution, that thought thinking
that we can have this, uh,
encoder decoder kind of architecture.
This is one of the possibility to handle the sequence
to sequence problem, right?
And people came up with this
and then, then they did the training and testing.
And I'll explain more on that, that how
to do the training in this case.
What is, how the training time is
different from testing time.
Those things will, will talk more on that.
So machine translation is one of the use case.
You can always apply with other kind of use case.
Also, for example, I'll give the whole paragraph
as an input here in the encoder,
and I can ask you to summarize this in a two line.
So summarization is another kind of sequence
to sequence problem, because paragraph is also a sequence
and summarization of in the two line is also a sequence.
So se that is also a sequence to sequence problem
question answering is another kind
of sequence to sequence problem.
So question is also a sequence.
Answer is also a sequence, right?
So likewise, you can just assume
that whatever is the sequence to sequence problem, uh,
we have that that can all be, uh, can, can be addressed
with this kind of network, okay?
And this encoded decoded is one such architecture
to handle the sequence to sequence problem.
There might be some other architecture also,
but the sequence to sequence modeling is
one such architecture.
And it is very important to understand this architecture
because this has become later the, the, you can say genesis
for this transformer or large language model.
Because in the large language model, also, when we were in,
uh, you were, you were learning that in the first semester,
generative, we have shown you the architecture right there.
Also, we have the encoder and decoder network.
So the idea of having the encoder decoder type of network,
what's first introduced in the sequence
to sequence language model, okay?
So you can go and you can actually learn, uh,
you can check this, uh, uh, uh, sequence to
seek, to seek, we say paper, okay?
To get into the
sequence to sequence learning with the neural network.
Now, this paper is also come in 2014.
Around 2014,
first time this architecture was proposed, okay?
Again, by the Google. Uh, so this, this paper was given,
and this is the first time they said that, oh,
this is the type of architecture.
If we can, if we can create, then we can handle the variable
and sequence in the input also output also create the
sequence to sequence sort of architectures.
And it is better than only having the
encoder type of network.
What we have, what we have been, uh, developing so far
with LSTM or GRU.
Okay? So what I'll recommend that again, you go
and, uh, read this paper in your, in your free time
to understand the sequence to sequence, uh,
that this architecture
and what else else they have done in this particular,
uh, paper, right?
It'll give you a nice understanding about this, okay?
So what the plan is,
although I'm not going into the detail today, as I said,
I'm just giving you some exposure.
So this, this paper link is here also, I'll, I'll share
that anyway, when it'll come, I'll share this.
Everything I will.
So the, so the point is, uh, this, this has become,
uh, you can say that very, I, uh, i important paper
for the transformer as well.
This has given the idea that how we can, uh,
address the sequence to sequence modeling fine.
Here, obviously we are using LSTM in transformer,
we have removed the LSTM came up
with different architecture, but sequence to sequence,
this was still there in the transformer architecture.
Okay? Now going forward, we will also see that
how the sequence to sequence model, uh,
what was the problem in the sequence to sequence model.
So that later on we came up
with this transformer architecture.
So you, do you see that in 2014 this paper was proposed,
okay, this architecture was proposed
and it sustained, you can say that for two, three years,
I mean this architecture is still there, sequence
to sequence in transformer.
So we used, but suddenly we realized
that having the LSTM has the bottleneck.
And the other problem was there is no attention, uh, which,
uh, which we are, which we have here,
which we have in the self, uh,
in the transformer self attention sort of case.
So within two to three years, people realized
that there are some limitation in this architecture.
We came up with two, 2017
around this transformer architecture.
But from then on that the,
that the same architecture we are, we are using
that same transformer architecture is still there almost
nine years down the line.
We is still using the same architecture.
So indeed this uh, LLM uh,
transform architecture is very powerful, right?
And that's why it could sustain
with this technological 2020, uh, when we are in the,
uh, uh, uh, this, the century
and still something has sustained for nine year,
i it must have some very high capability.
That is what you will learn in the next core
LM large language model.
That why it could sustain
and why the other networks could only, uh, lasted
for two years, one year, three years.
But obviously those contributions were always important
to have, uh, without having these understanding at the
initial layer, initial level in 2014, having the paper
of transformer where they have used this encoded decoded
architecture wouldn't have been possible.
So every research was important, I would say,
and this is how we have progressed.
Okay? So yeah, so I guess I should stop here.
Maybe I'll take you through this journey maybe
with this more, more interesting mysteries, what is
behind in the coming classes, right?
Uh, so I'll stop here maybe if you have any quick question
on these lines, you can ask me.
Otherwise, we'll meet on Saturday to continue
Anything.
Alright, so my,
my suggestion is please keep on doing the practice with the
change, the data change slightly in the model, right?
Uh, because that is very important, uh, side by side
because you have to also look
after the long-term project, what you are doing
and you have to implement everything.
So keep on doing and come up with the
questions if you have any from the hands-on part as well.
If you have any fine. So that you can always ask me, okay?
Yeah, sure, sir. Yeah.
So I guess we can stop here then
and we'll meet one second.
Thank you. Seven good nights. Thank you, sir.
Thank, thank sir. Thank sir, sir.
Thank you, sir. Thank.